[Music]
on this Wednesday night the wallets of
Canadians get squeezed even further the
Bank of Canada raises its rate again the
broader implications of rising debt are
social cohesion is suffering plus the
hint rate hikes will be paused
ramping up reinforcements Germany and
the U.S agree to send tanks to Ukraine
what about Canada
the Pope says homosexuality is not a
crime and criticizes anti-gay laws
plus saving endangered stories of a
Montreal suburb I'm doing a service to
the kids who are growing up here one
man's labor of love
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a major development
that could change the direction of the
war in Ukraine Germany and the U.S have
agreed to send battle tanks to Ukraine
the German government also clearing away
for other countries including Canada to
send german-made tanks Ukraine has
lobbied for this for months President
Vladimir zelenski's Chief of Staff said
today the tanks will form a crushing
fist against Russia tanks are primarily
offensive weapons and could be used to
drive out Russian forces from areas
they've occupied and that the Russian
Embassy in Berlin has said will take the
conflict to a new level of Confrontation
Eric Sorensen reports
it is a potential turning point in the
war german-made leopard tanks will soon
be on their way to Ukraine from all over
Europe more modern Firepower than
Ukraine has had up to now big
announcements came from both sides of
the Atlantic in Berlin German Chancellor
Olaf Schultz after weeks of pressure
from allies announced that Germany would
send tanks to Ukraine
trust me and trust the German government
said Schultz addressing historic
concerns about Germany's expanding role
in the European War stating this is in
coordination with the International
Community in Washington U.S President
Joe Biden for the first time committed
American offensive Firepower 31 Advanced
M1 Abrams Tanks that's what this is
about helping Ukraine defend and protect
Ukrainian land it is not an offensive
threat to Russia but how will Moscow
view this reason enough to use even more
deadly weapons Russian President
Vladimir Putin spoke to students today
but did not directly address the tanks
Putin said Russia's goal is to defend
itself and the territories that it
claims clearly what we're going to see
happening is threats from the Russians
um that if you do this then we will have
to respond but it's not clear exactly
what they will do the country's
promising german-made leopard tanks
include Germany with an initial
commitment of 14 tanks Poland 14 tanks
smaller numbers from Norway Finland the
Netherlands and Spain the UK is sending
14 of its Challenger tanks the U.S will
send 31 Abrams Tanks what Canada and
other countries will decide is uncertain
Just A Week Ago Ottawa pledged to send
200 armored personnel carriers to
Ukraine but will Canada send any of its
own leopard tanks we will continue to be
there to give whatever support we can to
Ukraine I won't be making an
announcement today but I can tell you we
are looking very very closely at what
more we can do to support Ukraine the
first tanks for Ukraine will obviously
come from Europe Ukraine's President
Vladimir zielinski sent thanks first to
the German Chancellor for sending tanks
and for the green light for other
countries to do likewise then hours
later to President Biden for American
tanks declaring today the Free World is
United as never before Russia is
expected to launch a new offensive in
the spring what's not clear is whether a
fortified Ukrainian military could
shorten the war or prolong it Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
so back to that question of where does
this leave Canada the Prime Minister not
ruling out sending some of our leopard
two tanks Mercedes Stevenson is with me
from Ottawa Mercedes what are you
hearing Donna I'm hearing there could be
an announcement about Canada sending
tanks as soon as tomorrow that both the
political and Military level are gearing
up to try to find a way to send some
Canadian tanks but the options we have
are limited Canada only has 82 main
battle tanks that are capable of
actually fighting let's take a look at
what some of those options are the first
type is the two A4 M's we only have 20
of those and some of them may be
destined for Canadian troops in Latvia
then we have the two a6ms we only have
20 of those as well they were heavily
used in Afghanistan and they are booked
for retrofit finally we have the leopard
two a4s there are 42 of them and they
aren't used for deployments in Canada we
only use them for training but the
military sources I spoke to say they're
still better than anything that Russia
is using using right now in Ukraine and
that a number of allies are deploying
these so they would be interoperable I
spoke to the former Chief of the defense
staff Rick Hillier about what he thought
about a potential tank deployment and
this is what he had to say we've got to
play our role and and we've got to do
those things and yes will it cost us of
course it will well that's the price of
Freedom that's the price of stability
and that's the price of having an
environment in which Canada can Thrive
the question now is how many tanks too
few and it looks like tokenism to many
and it could gut the Canadian Army's
capability the military is worried about
whether or not it will see replacement
tanks and all of these questions
highlight the issue of defense spending
and frustration by both Canada's allies
and the military over what the
government has invested okay Mercedes
Stevenson and Ottawa thanks Ukraine has
pulled its troops from the key town of
solidar in the Donetsk region the
military calls it an organized Retreat
to preserve the lives of personnel
Russia claims the town is critical to
capturing all of the Eastern Don bass
region it moves Russian forces closer to
encircling the Strategic city of bakmut
Ukraine's withdrawal is a rare
Battlefield victory for Russia after
months of Retreats and one last note on
Ukraine it is President Vladimir
zielinski's 45th birthday his wife Elena
posted this tribute I'm often asked
about how you have changed this year she
writes and I always answer he is the
same the same guy I met when we were 17
but he smiles much less now
to Canada now and news anyone renewing
their mortgage was dreading the Bank of
Canada has hiked its Benchmark interest
rate again another attempt it says to
reduce inflation this eighth hike in
less than a year puts the bank rate at
4.5 percent the highest it's been since
2007. it only Rose 25 basis points today
which is the smallest single increase
seen since last March that's a bit of a
positive so his word the bank is pausing
rate hikes for now as Ann gaviolo
reports it's what Canadians struggling
with debt wanted to hear
the Central Bank expects inflation to
ease to 3 percent by mid-year we know it
takes time for higher interest rates to
work through the economy to slow demand
and reduce inflation
and given the speed and magnitude of the
interest rate increases over the last
year their full effect is still to come
it is the first major Central Bank to
say it may pause on monetary policy
tightening we are not out of the woods
yet so this coming March when the Bank
of Canada makes its next interest rate
decision we're kind of hoping that it's
going to just hold steady at 4.5 percent
here's what the rate hike means for a
typical variable rate mortgage on an
average home in Toronto monthly mortgage
payments jump to more than twenty eight
hundred dollars that's an increase of
246 dollars in Montreal that works out
to an extra 186 dollars monthly
according to polling by ipsos
exclusively for Global News 54 are
struggling to stay afloat financially
more than one in five say they're
completely out of money and can't afford
any more household expenses younger
Canadians and women groups that
typically earn less and were
disproportionately harmed financially
during the pandemic more likely to say
they're on the brink High inflation and
climbing interest rates seem to be
taking a broad social toll too
are social cohesion is suffering the
data is very clear that you know when
faced with hardships the attitude is
more you know I've got to take care of
myself and we are not in this together
and that has far-reaching implications
those implications include mistrust of
businesses politicians and institutions
including the Central Bank in another
first the Bank of Canada will share a
summary of the debate that led to its
decision but will have to wait two weeks
for that it is the central bank's
attempt to improve transparency on
setting monetary policy Donna all right
angaviola thanks now to developments at
The Retreat prime minister Justin
Trudeau is holding with Federal cabinet
ministers in Hamilton Ontario a small
but vocal group of protesters has been
making their views known outside the
hotel and the venue where the retreat is
happening last night they confronted
ministers on the street there's lots of
swearing we're only going to show you a
small part of it
protesters shouted profanities at
Trudeau and some of his ministers
calling the Prime Minister a tyrant
among other things there was a heavy
police presence the protests seemed to
be about public health restrictions
which are no longer in place today the
Prime Minister was asked about the anger
expressed
it's really really important in our
democracy that people can express their
disagreement or displeasure or even
anger with various governments that's
really important and at the same time
our police services and institutions
will ensure that those those protests
remain peaceful and law-abiding the
cabinet Retreat wrapped up today with
news about health care or at least talks
about health care the Prime Minister has
agreed to meet with the premiers next
month they have repeatedly asked for
more money for Health Care setting up a
meeting though doesn't guarantee a
resolution Toria Israel looks at the
expectations
liberals have got their free
[Applause]
when happened yet getting the most
attention prime minister Justin Trudeau
invited the premiers to Ottawa to try to
hash out a funding deal on health care
what we'll be doing in two weeks when we
sit down is rolling up our sleeves and
talking about what we're proposing as
the shape of the path forward for health
care in this country the data set for
February 7th but Trudeau is trying to
keep expectations low we're not going to
be signing deals on that particular
moment despite the downplaying the
Liberals insist in agreement is Within
Reach oh maybe we're coming around the
final lap I mean pick your analogy maybe
we're in the third period the invitation
comes after a months-long impasse
between the federal government and
provinces the Prime Minister insists to
quote appropriate amount of money is on
the table but did not give a specific
amount
Ottawa transferred 45 billion dollars in
health care spending to the provinces
this year the premiers want another 28
billion in the belief of all the
premiers from the provinces and
territories that if we just get around a
table together and talk it through that
we could get a deal the federal
government plans to hammer out an
agreement with each Premier to address
each province's Health Care priorities
all in exchange for certain conditions
we need to share data better between
provinces and better access to mental
health care and a more Modern Health
Data A system that will help save lives
the system as a whole is overwhelmed
with clogged emergency rooms surgery
backlogs and staff shortages
conservative leader Pierre pauliev says
it's unbelievable a meeting with the
premiers has taken this long what
matters is that we get shorter wait
times more doctors and nurses and faster
approval of new drugs and treatments for
our people more details on the premier's
they trickle out later this week when
the liberal caucus meets for their
Retreat the last strategy session before
Parliament returns Donna okay turia
Israeli in Hamilton tonight thanks now
to Toronto and those attacks on Transit
passengers and staff the head of one of
Canada's major Transit unions is calling
for a national task force to come up
with potential Solutions in Toronto it's
happened again late this afternoon a 16
year old boy was stabbed on a bus the
fourth violent incident reported this
week on the city's transit system and
this morning two Toronto Transit workers
were reportedly chased by someone with a
syringe neither employee was hurt the
suspect was arrested yesterday a woman
was stabbed on A Streetcar and on Monday
bus drivers were swarmed by a group of
teenage boys Toronto's Mayor John Tory
says it's time to respond to what he
calls Canada's Mental Health crisis he
wants a summit with leaders from
municipalities the premiers and the
federal government
when we were you know dealing with the
pandemic together we dealt with it
together we got the job done in a way
that we could be proud of around the
world and I think it's time we took on
something that's been around for a lot
longer than the pandemic namely mental
health and did exactly the same thing
members of Municipal and provincial
governments in Ontario say they support
the idea
Canada's housing Minister on the
defensive coming up why he is doubling
down on contracts he gave to a marketing
firm
an update now to a story Global News
broke last week housing Minister Ahmed
Hussein gave several Federal contracts
for political Communications work to an
agency that specializes in marketing
food and the agency's head is the sister
of one of The Minister's senior staff
our reporter caught up with the minister
to ask about all this Mackenzie gray is
with me now Mackenzie what did he have
to say
well Donna we've been trying to
interview Ahmed Hussein for the past
week and when our team finally caught up
with him he wasn't happy to see the
cameras they're trying to get an answer
from here I issued a statement to you
and the
that is very comprehensive the housing
Minister eventually stopped and defended
giving 93 000 worth of constituency
communications contracts to a
food-oriented PR firm that is owned by a
senior staffer's sister all the rules
were followed we checked with the
financial management office as well as
proactively seeking the guidance of the
office of the conflict of interest and
ethics commissioner we asked the ethics
commissioner's office and they wouldn't
confirm what advice Mario Dion gave to
the housing minister or if they even
spoke Hussein even left the door open to
giving much more media more business
would you hire them again
um well I was happy with the services
and and I I was happy that they assisted
me to communicate to my constituents
despite how pleased he was who sends
office decline to provide examples of
work that the company did for him the
Prime Minister wouldn't say if he
thought rehiring the firm would be
appropriate it's important of course
that people follow all the rules and
that's what we'll continue to ensure as
for the company they're trying to change
their recipe for Success at least online
after taking down their website they've
posted a new one it doesn't mention
their political experience but it bills
the company is having an in-depth
understanding of the media landscape but
they haven't forgotten their Roots we've
been specializing in the food industry
for many years it says women and gender
equality Minister Marcy Ian seemed to
miss that Focus despite giving the firm
two contracts worth ten thousand dollars
are we sure that it was just a foodie PR
firm I can check with my constituency
office but as far as I know Facebook ads
were bought and that's what was done
just like Hussein Ian defended giving
the contracts to much more media saying
that she didn't know that the owner of
the company was the sister of Ahmed
Hussein's policy advisor Donna Mackenzie
gray in Ottawa thank you a rare
interview with the Pope ahead what he
said about homosexuality and his
potential retirement
when Pope Francis took over as head of
the Catholic Church 10 years ago he made
it clear he was going to do things
differently he lives a more frugal life
than past popes doesn't live in the
official papal residence and he's
talking more to the media today Pope
Francis did an interview with Associated
Press sharing his use on retirement his
health and homosexuality sending a clear
message to others in the church Crystal
gomancing Reports
whether in the Vatican the United Arab
Emirates or Canada the 86 year old
pontiff has the ear of the world and it
appears Pope Francis wants everyone to
know he's all right he's just getting
older
I'm in good health for my age I'm normal
when Pope Benedict the 16th died
recently questions surfaced about
francis's health and his future Benedict
sent shockwaves through the church as
the first pope in 600 years to retire
setting old age and health concerns
Francis says if he were to resign he
would move to a residence for retired
priests and Bishops in Rome
at the end of January the pope will
visit the Democratic Republic of Congo
and South Sudan a pilgrimage that was
postponed last year the head of the
Roman Catholic Church preaches peace and
for a less judgmental community that
often leads to questions about the
lgbtq2 community
being homosexual is not a crime speaking
to the Associated Press in Spanish he
said laws focusing on same-sex activity
are unjust for Advocates like Frank
teston the Pope's words are essential
for life and dignity I think his message
today is a clear
um instruction to this ships worldwide
to stop
supporting the criminalization of
homosexual romantic Behavior the pope
did say it is a sin in the church but he
also pointed out it's a sin to lack
charity it's a prophetic stance taken by
the pope and I'm delighted to see it
especially when the words come before a
Papal visit to South Sudan where
same-sex activity between men is against
the law Crystal gomancing Global News
London
class from the past next how a Quebec
filmmaker is preserving a Montreal
suburbs history
[Music]
a Quebec videographer is on a mission to
romanticize the suburbs specifically the
one where he grew up on Montreal's West
Island Jason bolanus has Enlisted the
help of local seniors and historical
archives in an effort to hold on to
stories that might otherwise be lost as
Mike Armstrong explains he wants to make
the mundane memorable for his
community's next generation
just where we are specifically was
Forest there was little patches of
forest this is one of those places with
more history than most people realize
it's just a quiet Corner in the town of
Point Claire unless you're with Jason
balanis but what happened here in 1953
was that there was a plane crash right
here right here eight men died in that
crash but today it's mostly forgotten I
remember parachutes stuck in trees
before it fades from memory videographer
Jason bolanus interviewed people who
were there when it happened it was
horrible but you couldn't see her anyway
they were they were all they were all
dead it may be clear now that I have a
slight Obsession about the history of
this place now that story is just one of
dozens balanis has been collecting he's
produced a series on YouTube about the
history of the suburbs where he grew up
sometimes it's about things that
happened like the first air show in
Canada in 1910 people from all around
the country came to see it you ever
wonder what Halloween was like sometimes
it's just about what life was like as
forests and Farms were replaced by
houses the water would come up so high
the city would have to put some wood so
why become an expert in Suburban history
because no one's doing it I got no
competition
there may be a reason you don't have any
body but you know but I feel like I'm uh
I'm doing a service to the kids who are
growing up here to know that they're not
just growing up in Suburbia but but
they're growing up in a pretty
interesting part of Montreal it does
look quite unrecognizable another part
of this passion project is understanding
how things developed the way they did
and why Atlanta says if you understand
how we got here life makes a bit more
sense it also makes things not as
serious to know that this is what ends
up happening this is a a progressive
evolution of things so you don't take
things too seriously when you're in the
moment of something you know it helped
me during the pandemic the woman that
lived in this house with each story
balanis says he uncovers others he's not
likely to run out of ideas he says he's
actually having trouble just getting out
of the 1950s oh can we use any of this
yet
epic Armstrong Global News Point Claire
Quebec I love that that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's here in Canada is the
ganaraska bridge in Fort Hope Ontario
bye-bye
[Music]